spring in Moscow but for Russians
finally enjoying the sunshine there's
still a chill in the air the fear their
government May soon call them up to
fight in Ukraine
yeah no I'm very afraid I obviously
don't want it to happen if you're
interested in whether I personally would
like to go no let's just say I'm in the
reserve so I probably would go
as a law-abiding citizen I wouldn't have
a choice right so it's not my choice as
Russians prepare for Monday's Victory
Day their government denies General
mobilization is about to be announced
but human rights groups have told us
reservists are already being contacted
by authorities in what could be the
first stage in a national call-up
we're getting calls on the hotline
lately starting from April with people
saying that reservists have been called
into recruitment offices the
registration details are being checked
they're addressed their marital status
their health and whatever the Kremlin
says reservers have confirmed to Sky
News they have been called into
recruitment offices we understand that
recruitment officers have been talking
to reservists across Russia about the
possibility of being mobilized can you
rule out we put the claims to the
foreign Ministry
these statements have already been
denied by the Russian officials so let's
proceed from that a straight answer was
given there's nothing I can add
but then Vladimir Putin's claimed
conscripts and reservists haven't been
fighting in Ukraine when we know they
have
yes let me point out that conscripts
have not and will not take place in
military action and reservists will not
be called up only professional military
men are resolving the problem
Kremlin insisted Ukraine would not be
attacked when it has claims it won't use
Victory Day to expand its campaign there
may not be all that reassuring to
Russians worried they could soon be
called on to fight
Dominic waghorn Sky News Moscow